I asked a question to the universe which
then my cells answered I asked a
question when I just realized and I
exist as a field energy a spirit
whatever you want to call it as
information in the field and it also
exists as a body my first question that
came up in my head was then why have
both why have a spirit and a body why
not just be the spirit I ask why have
both and all of a sudden welled up and
the answer came and said Bruce if you're
just a spirit what does chocolate taste
like and all of a sudden I said oh my
God it's the biology which is all the
receptor devices that translate my
environment into sensation which are
then translated by the nervous system
into fields and and vibrational patterns
which are then sent back to my source
and I realized at that moment I said my
God we're here to experience this place
to touch it and smell it watch sunsets
and feel loved and eat wonderful food
and then all of a sudden it says yeah
but it's not just receiving information
when you have a body you can be creative
we can come to this planet and manifest
creativity and we do this we step into a
virtual reality suit called the body I
step into the suit as a spirit it
communicates with me via just the same
way the Mars rover is communicating with
NASA and I get to experience this planet
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Bruce Lipton and my take on his top 50
rules of success enjoy
the belief that James turned on and off
is taking power away from the individual
because if the genes were turning on and
off and I did not control them then by
definition I am a victim of which genes
did I get from my family did cancer
genes come in the heart disease genes or
diabetes and now we recognize that in
regard to disease genes are responsible
for less than 10 percent of disease in
fact there are indications that genes
are only responsible for one percent of
disease so all of a sudden it says well
wait we used to think genes cause
disease but if only a small percent of
disease is controlled by genes and where
is the disease coming from that is
affecting the world the answer is now we
know from epigenetics Consciousness
lifestyle belief systems these are the
ultimate controls of the gene we know
that if you've got a cancer Gene and
that's what you believe then you think
I'm going to get the cancer and then you
get a Cancer and you say the genes did
it and now we know no that there is no
cancer Gene there is not one gene that
causes cancer genes are correlated with
cancer meaning if your life is not in
Harmony and you have one of these genes
you can activate a cancer
50 percent of the women that have the
same brca1 gene never get the cancer the
point is very important having the gene
doesn't mean you've got cancer but
having the Gene and not living in
harmony not living in a healthy
lifestyle that causes the cancer
and so we have to help people take them
from the belief I'm a victim and give
them the science that no your
Consciousness is creating this life
experience in here your Consciousness is
controlling your genes cells in your
body are not connected to the outer
environment but they have to adjust
themselves to that outer environment and
the relevance about that well then how
they know what to do because something
has to tell them what the heck is going
on and so it turns out the nervous
system
interfaces the environment and then
sends signals to the cells to tell them
what's going on so the cells are
responding to the perceptions and
actions of the central nervous system
and I say why is that relevant because I
say it's an interpretation and so the
cells the simple point you got 50
trillion citizens and the conscious the
mind is the government yes and the
government talks to these cells now you
can have a bad uh leader who tells them
this is all crap it's all falling apart
things don't work and it's like they're
not going to be happy cells and it can
profoundly different you talk to
yourselves and tell them okay
everything's cool we're great
when there's a big you know in the U.S
an accident or you know big big problem
in some Community the president goes to
the community yes why does the president
go because it takes the attention of all
the other citizens of the of the states
focuses on the intention where that
president is so if there's an area where
there's a disaster the energy of all the
people are addressed to that area
because the president shows up there and
that's the leader so I'm saying the same
thing for yourselves you're sort of that
president in there and the point is when
you touch some part on your body your
conscious attention focuses on that part
of the body and intention is energy and
it's a healing energy when you're
sending a good message uh to that part
of advice so you touch it talk to it and
it sounds like oh crazy I go no you are
directly sending information be your
Consciousness to all the cells to focus
healing on this part if you change the
picture in your mind you change the
chemistry you change the Fate so I'll
give an example
if I have a picture of Love in My Mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says that
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances Vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture media but now I say but wait
what if I have a picture of fear I go oh
well love chemistry doesn't come out
when fear is in the picture the brain
releases stress hormones and factors
that affect the immune system and growth
of the system and I go oh my goodness I
say why is it relevant changing my
thought changes my chemistry the
chemistry adjusts my biology so if I can
control my thoughts I can control the
chemistry and therefore I control the
biology that takes me to empowerment
Mastery after being programmed by
medicine and biology all these years
that you're just a victim of your genes
that's 100 false genes cannot turn on
and off by themselves they're controlled
by the signals of the environment which
are then controlled by the brain and the
Consciousness and all of a sudden it
says yeah but I control those things I
go yes you do and as a result you have
power
to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there in today's world I love the phrase
because it is funny but it's true
you want to be happy well do you have to
habituate happy you have to say every
day no matter if you don't if you're not
happy I don't really care you have to
tell yourself I am happy I am happy you
have to repeat it ah habituation
repetition why I'm consciously repeating
it every day and look at my life my life
really sucks oh Bruce I am happy I am
I'm saying that I go well why are you
saying it because repetition is how the
subconscious mind learns I say why is
this relevant and here's the fun part
because after I've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay I am
happy as I've learned this I go why is
it relative that 95 of the day the
subconscious function is to make that
program real if my program is I am happy
the function of the mind is to make sure
I'm happy if the if the program says I'm
going to get cancer because I heard that
from somebody else then the function of
the mind is to make sure I get cancer
because that's the belief I'm working
with
and if if it says I am a victim and I
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you I'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because I'm running the show you're a
victim how did you learn anything after
age seven and the answer was repetition
that's what it was was just practicing
the more you repeat something the more
it becomes just so easy you don't know
how to play an instrument you practice
like crazy at some point you practice so
much you pick up the instrument no
consciousness of the details of how
you're playing it it's so automatic at
this point it's like driving a car
when you first got in the cars like oh
my God you gotta watch the window the
mirrors the gauges the engine sound
every yes like so much today you've been
driving a car a long time guess what
you don't even think about it but the
key in you're thinking about where
you're going and all of a sudden I saw
the more you practice the less effort it
takes to carry out whatever it was you
were practicing now the question is what
are you practicing something positive or
something negative because they're both
become programs whichever one you're
practicing if I have a picture of fear
in my mind I'm afraid of something my
brain translates fear with different
chemicals stress hormones cortisol
norepinephrine factors that affect the
immune system that are called cytokines
or histamine so basically in a state of
conscious fear the brain releases
chemistry that complements fear that
chemistry goes into the body's blood and
that changes the behavior and the
genetics of the person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts and people say
oh that positive thinking doesn't really
work but that's not true the best
example of positive thinking in a
scientific study is called Placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
his new pill and it's the brand new
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill so then you're left with so what
made me well it's not the sugar pill it
was the positive belief in that sugar
pill and how it's going to help your
life so that's called Placebo positive
thinking positive result unfortunately
most people don't recognize a more
important Point negative thinking is
equally powerful but it works in the
opposite direction
so it turns out for example less than 10
percent of cancer is even connected to a
family lineage ninety percent of cancer
just comes out of the blue so to speak
but the reality is no it's a result of
stress and negative thinking so it's
important Point positive thinking
negative thinking equally powerful
because that's the level of
Consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics
I just want to add a very important
point to this quantum physics is the
most valid science on this planet there
is no science that has been tested more
and verified more I guess so what's the
relevance because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
Consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of Our Lives I am so
grateful to offer this because as each
one of us takes back our power and each
one of us actually starts to live heaven
on Earth like you did when you fell in
love even if it was only for a week
if you could do that every day of your
life and everyone around you is doing
that every day of your life then the
simple truth is this and Earth does
become Heaven if we're all living as if
it's Heaven and the function is to
create the minds is to take that vision
and manifest it if I believe I'm living
in heaven then my world experience will
be what would it be like if I lived in
heaven and being in love is the one time
you unconsciously unknowingly
took back power the equivalent of the
record you unknowingly became powerful
and I said yeah in 24 hours you changed
your whole demeanor of life after you
met this person yeah I go
you you could have done it in different
ways didn't have to be with a person you
didn't need to fall in love with a
person you could fall in love with uh
gardening yeah if you're a gardener you
go out in the garden and you're digging
the garden you're having so much fun and
the plants are growing and everything I
go you just manifested heaven on Earth
for you it's not beautiful living in the
garden I go well it doesn't have to be
another person the love doesn't love Is
Just focusing on something you desire
a pet a garden artwork cleaning up the
garage
yeah because when I'm doing it I'm
creating order and happiness and all
that I go well fine then you're cleaning
out the garage I go to clean up the damn
garage so if you're cleaning up because
wow that's so much better now I feel so
much better in here it's so clean I know
where everything is I go
being in love doesn't have it could be
anything that keeps your conscious mind
in front because it's when your
conscious mind goes in the back is when
you become the product of your
subconscious program
so
um and this is great the hardest part
about programming that people don't
recognize is you have to make all
programs present tense positive
statements not future statements I will
have I shall have you know something
like that say no I am it is and the
reason is it's logically simple not as
this uh let's say I'm not well I say I
want to be well I say fine let's record
that now let's come back a whole year
later and push the button it says I want
to be well I say oh it's been a whole
year you never got there you just wanted
to be well for a whole year that's what
the program said so if you are sick and
you write I am healthy and the mind
looks at the program says oh I got to
change this it doesn't change the
program it brings health back so that
the body matches the program and so that
that's the whole issue about it the
function of the mind is to take the pro
program and manifest it and if you got a
negative program then obviously whatever
manifest is going to be negative here we
go
[Music]
and then you can look at it oh oh I
reckon I'm good on that okay okay great
I don't know thank you
[Music]
Up Up and Away oh hold on a second hold
on Laura welcome to funkmeister Studios
where all the magic happens we have a
belief that only physical matter is
primary and we've ignored the relevance
of what's called Energy and the new
physics quantum physics says you can't
ignore the energy the energy is what is
actually shaping the physical world so
by leaving the energy out of the
equation we've missed the the most
important factor spirituality mind is
energy everything we eat food is energy
where we live is energy so we have to
talk about the environment
of the invisible nature is what's
actually shaping our physical experience
on this planet it's a retake and it says
look stop focusing on this physical
plane start recognizing your thoughts
and your beliefs and spirituality and
energy around us are really reflected in
who we are right now today the world's
in a big mess and the significance of
that is who's responsible and it turns
out it's a very small percent of the
population that we would call the
leaders of our civilization
for me what would be really important is
this if all individuals would fully
Express their power guess what there's a
commonality to all people on this planet
what do they want health happiness a job
security food well if we're all sharing
those wishes guess what we would all
live in harmony seeking the same very
ends and so for me it is really
important that people Empower themselves
because our leadership is not really
supporting us as much as the mass of
population because collectively we would
have a much better outlook on this
planet than the one we're experiencing
right now please listen to this
a negative thought is equally powerful
in controlling the biology so as much as
a positive thought can heal you a
negative thought can kill you it can
make any disease you can have a negative
thought about cancer and manifest cancer
you have no no genes that are even
cancer related genes and it's like where
the hell did it come from you are
creating your biology as a complement to
what you see
so if you see a positive world then
you're getting Positive Vibes coming in
and it feels really great and if you
live in a negative world or one you
believe to be negative then the cells
are inside cowering going oh my God it's
not safe out there uh and and so my
cells are just adjusting to my
perception so changing your perception
is like well where's that and I go
that's your mind just to begin with a
very interesting concept that
um
judeo-christianity has provided the
large population of the world with a
belief
that Genesis occurred and God created
the planet and the water and then the
animals and the plants and after all
this creation then God said let's add
some humans to the mix so we didn't come
from that creation we were added to the
Earth
science comes in and also separates us
from the planet because conventional
science based on what is called
Newtonian physics we are physical
particles separate from each other no
we're all separate pieces and we lost
the understanding that the word Gaia is
a living organism the Earth is a cell we
are connected to everything we've lost
that Vision we feel that we are at peace
in a in a bunch of pieces and as I said
are we going to be safe or are we going
to be afraid in this and I said then we
want to protect ourselves and if you
understand the breathing of most people
it's very shallow it's right up here why
I don't want to take too much of the
outside in I'm protecting myself but as
you said we we still need oxygen so we
breathe in a little bit of oxygen but we
want to be separate
and the simple reality is those beliefs
are totally false we were created with
everything we are created from
everything there is no separation
between us and the world in which we
live
and so when we are breathing very
shallow we are actually remember I said
protection close yourself down shallow
breathing closing yourself down when you
start to learn to take in the breath of
life you are opening yourself to the
entire world around us
and that opening of the world makes us
part of this world not A Separate Peace
from one another
so breathing becomes a very important
part of am I hiding from the World by
just breathing a little tiny bit or can
I take in this breath and become part of
this Oneness that we are your separation
is where all the problems of life come
from
your breathing can open you up
to this entire world to take it in you
are this world you are every bit of this
you're a reflection of everything out
there you came from that
so basically can we stop the protection
that we think is helping us but it's the
protection that is killing us
and breathing can I take this in
can I take the world in yes
and I can Thrive and so when we start to
let go of that protection the breathing
will start to go from shallow chest to
abdominal because I'm taking in the
world with every breath I'm taking in
the energy of the world with every
breath and that is what makes us whole
you have shallow breathing you have fear
all of a sudden you cannot be whole
anymore
and so we come here to learn to take
power back
and and oh my God Closing word yoga
another major assumption is that we're
equivalent to genetic automatons we have
genes they control us we don't control
the genes and therefore we're sort of
like victims of our heredity you've got
cancer running in your family say oh my
goodness I'm going to get the cancer I
got the genes or Alzheimer's or diabetes
whatever this is completely false
because it turns out genes control
nothing it's really the environment that
is controlling the genes and more
importantly our perception of the
environment how we see the world what we
think about the world is adjusting our
genetics so we find out disease one
percent of disease is connected to
genetics 90 or more of diseases
connected to how we live in the world
because how we live in the world is
altering or affecting our genetic
activity so what we know and what we
believe is changing our reality
constantly right because the noob
scientists call that genetics and what
it means is this our beliefs and how we
see the world we change our genetics so
and rather than being victims which we
have believed all the way up to now we
are the Masters we change our genetics
just by how we respond to the world so
we can change our responses which means
then we can change our genetics so we're
not victims a very important part of our
understanding about life is that it's
our perception of Life which actually
means our beliefs about life so the
significance is if you're going to plan
your life and you're going to make
perceptions the programmer of your life
well then the best thing you can do is
perceive of the life that you would wish
and desire because those thoughts will
be translated by biology into the
expression of your cells and your
genetics and you will manifest your
wishes and your desires and that's what
the new biology is all about all you
need is love and and we really have to
recognize that love is a vibration it's
not a physical thing it's a feeling that
people look at and it's it's a Harmony
and this is what love is versus fear
love is Harmony music it all comes
together beautifully fear is noise
disharmony and a Breaking of the
vibrational Harmony and so really it's
like bring it back together again and
bring everything back into harmony the
the planet the environment ourselves our
community of humanity and and when it is
in harmony it is love
and so that's the message that that was
really brought from this Center uh
through the Beatles
and and given to the world
all you need is love for me one of the
most personally exciting things that
happened to my life was to recognize
that I was not a victim a victim of my
genes or a victim of my society that I
actually am a creator of my life and
once understanding that nature and
expressing that creativity I profoundly
changed my life from being a victim to
being a master of my creation and today
I have such a wonderful life that it
actually has no comparison to the first
40 years of my life where I lived under
the programming that I received as a
child today I've created such a joyous
wonderful life that I look forward every
day to waking up to have another day on
this beautiful planet the most profound
teachers I ever sat before
to have the opportunity to learn the
lessons that were so magnificent that I
can't fully put them into words
and who were those teachers
they were the cells that I was working
on in a Petri dish they showed me for my
point of view and my reference to life
that there was something called
spirituality that I didn't know existed
and The Moment I Saw the mechanics of
how a signal
from the universe comes in to my
body suit my virtual reality suit and
was running this there was this instant
of recognition I said oh my God I can't
die
I'm not even in here
that's concept of immortality was one of
the
first and most important lessons I had
why because all of us when we grew up as
children there was a point of learning
that people die
and that you are people and that you
will do so yourself and your parents
will die and your friends and loved ones
will also die
and we get so caught up in that the
moment of reality that I couldn't die
was the most uplifting experience I
could ever imagine because the fear
that we are programmed with that you may
not say every day oh I'm afraid of dying
you don't have to say it it's built into
your subconscious it's running your life
every movement you make every action you
take there's something in your mind that
says how's this going to affect my life
am I going to threaten My Life by doing
this there's another person going to
threaten my life and we get into that
so for me the truest knowledge I got was
not a Devotion to Spirit it was an
owning of spirit it was owning it
without saying I think it's this way I
owned it and the moment I owned it a
weight that I ever knew I was even
carrying around
disappeared because I became free for
the first time to recognize I'm here for
something other than my life
the cells taught me this as well and the
cells also taught me what I mentioned
briefly the other day the next important
factor when you put the two together
and that is
that we have been programmed
in this world
not to love ourselves we've been
programmed to be criticized we have
parents who criticize us we have
teachers who criticize us we have people
all around that criticize us so what
does that mean every action you take
there's something back there the program
of critical criticism that says are you
doing it right are you doing it right
and then you live by this criticism
when you learn
that you're part of spirit as real
and you realize you're a part of
everything that is you're a part of if
you want to say God God how can you be
critical of God
and all of a sudden I started to realize
I cannot lead my life
in that critical nature I'm going to own
who I am
I'm a spirit that has come to this
planet to experience and to create and
to manifest Heaven on Earth and I have
now two lives I have previous learning
life struggle anger control trying to
fix everything and I have post
experience a calmness an understanding
that it's all driven by love even if
other people can't see through their
filter of criticism you're still driven
by love every one of you is a piece of
all that is every one of you
and if that critical mind comes up and
says not good enough in any sense
there's a point where you have to stand
back and say that's not me I am more
than the program
and when you let go
of that problem of self-criticism
you learn an experience for the first
time in your life self-love
and why is this important because as I
learned through years
I could not love
the people around me until I can learn
to love myself
it was always simple it was a joke in my
head somebody to say they love me and I
go
what kind of quality control do these
people have I can't love me how can they
love me
and I would reject and push away the
love because I couldn't own it to accept
it and if I could leave one message
behind about love is that you are loved
you are a piece of God that came here to
create the most beautiful thing in the
universe planet Earth
as we go outside and see nature and the
glory of this planet that's why we can
understand how beings from other places
or if anything jealous not to come here
to share in this beauty
so if I could just leave you with this
understanding you came here to create
Heaven other people took away your power
by programming you to criticize yourself
own who you are because then your
creative abilities will come forth and
guess what I found out I didn't have to
go out and make it happen I didn't have
to go out and beat the world to find
success to bring it in I just walked out
in love and it all came to me just like
every one of you here is a part of that
one love and when I come to uplift which
is the whole message to tell people we
are one love I get so elevated I was
behind the curtains back there when we
are made out of love was reverberating
through this building and you could feel
it you could feel it even if I couldn't
see you I was behind a curtain I could
feel the power of that love because you
were all so beautiful without your
filter
and so
recognizing that was a choice there's a
choice to say do I want to be the filter
or do I want to be me
and when you start to recognize me as
not just this isolated thing but me as
every one of you joining together is one
Collective all that is
the glory of Life on this planet cannot
be built by anything else in the
universe than what you can do here you
are creators
own your creativity own your spirit it's
not words it's not devotion
it's a true knowledge You Are Spiritual
and that is the opening of life
oh there's a no Sable alert on my Apple
hologram machine
oh I must go help Alex Dr nocebo is
giving him a lot of negative thinking
and what Alex doesn't recognize is that
negative thinking is equally powerful in
changing our lives as positive thinking
well the positive thinking can heal us
of any disease the placebo effect
negative thinking can cause any disease
and Alex is now going to have a whole
lot of negative thinking from Dr nocebo
we must go help Alex get his positive
thinking back online I must get down to
Alex right now and help him heal himself
in the past if you looked at him people
have perceived themselves as victims of
everything around them victims of
circumstances and then we go oh I'm I'm
sorry life did not give me those
wonderful things that other people have
and the simple reality is no no if you
have an issue it's not the outside this
is where we've always all Universe give
me something we now know that our issues
are internal it's our own subconscious
beliefs that we've been programmed with
of disempowerment like when a child is
growing up and getting its programs
think of what things parents say oh you
don't deserve this who do you think you
are I mean the parents didn't mean that
for your whole life they just they were
trying to you know goju you know it's
needle you to make a change so they
would say these things
95 of our life comes from those programs
so if you have disempowering beliefs
about who you think you are because you
got them from other people that's how
you know who you are
these disempowering beliefs play 95
percent of the day in an average
person's life so I say Yeah well my
wishes and desires are I want success I
want great relationships I want all
these wonderful I want health I go well
that's conscious Minds because conscious
mind's creative but uh as science
reveals only five percent of the day are
we operating from our own personal
wishes and desires 95 of the day we
operate from the programs that we got in
the first seven years and if those
programs which psychologists have told
us 70 percent are negative and
disempowering and self-sabotaging they
say good apply these 95 a day in your
life and you realize why your life is a
struggle it's not a struggle because the
universe is not providing it's a
struggle because your own Consciousness
is not accepting and this is where we
have to change and so getting control of
your mind taking charge of your
Consciousness is a way of overcoming
those limitations there are many
different ways to to take this control
back in in your life uh and one of them
is the ability to uh like in yoga for
example to be the master of your mind
and not let it run the monkey mind let
it run no I want this I don't don't let
this other one go the world is in a
state of evolution and what I mean by
evolution is not a physical Evolution
humans are not going to change into
something different
the evolution that we're really
experiencing now was an evolution in
consciousness
the Consciousness that has in the past
separated us as individuals
a Consciousness that has been programmed
with a belief that life is a struggle
and that we're out here to survive we
have to be in competition with each
other and undercut and undermine and we
were acting as individuals looking for
our own individual power
but in today's world there's a new
understanding that the evolution is an
evolution of Consciousness an evolution
of an expansion of we are more than just
these physical entities
that there is an energy involved in
Newtonian physics the conventional ones
that most people have learned atoms are
physical particles like little granules
but in 1925 physicists came to another
understanding because they said so what
are those particles made out of you
called atoms and they went inside and
they found they were smaller so-called
particles electrons protons and neutrons
but that still wasn't the quest because
what are they made out of and that's
when the world changed because when
Quantum physicists started to say what
is an electron or a proton or a neutron
made out of it's made out of energy not
physical no substance an atom is like a
nano tornado a spinning force field
there's an illusion that we are physical
entities you're an energy field
and I go so what the heck difference
does that make and I go well here's the
interesting part particles I can
separate here's a particle here's a
particle let's talk about one particle
energy just mixes all together I'm
sitting in a field of energy right now
so if I'm made out of energy which I am
doesn't mean that the edge of my energy
stops right here and the answer is no in
quantum mechanics I'm an energy field
wherever I go I'm like a broadcast
broadcasting and energy wherever you are
right now you're broadcasting energy and
so in a Newtonian world we grew up with
this is separate from this and that's
separate from this and I go in a quantum
mechanical world nothing is separate
everything is an energy field with no
borders to it so what I do in my world
is not just what I do in my world what I
do in my world is broadcast through
everything else and if it resonates or
is in harmony with you my energy can
affect your energy or my energy can
actually cancel your energy everything
is interconnected the chair I'm sitting
on is energy the air I'm in breathing
with is energy I'm energy your energy
we're all connected in this energy but
the fact is energies are Communications
and we vibrate and broadcast just like a
radio we're broadcasting who we are out
into the field and we alter what's going
on it is beyond language it's a
communication it has nothing to do with
words it's an energy that's available if
you just want to feel it and I think
that's the big issue feelings because
feelings are telling you you feel good
yes I'm having more energy you feel bad
you feel weak I'm having less energy I
say why is it relevant it's more
powerful than words energy can tell me
am I with people that are supporting me
because I feel good around them or do I
have a little quasi feeling of this it
doesn't feel right to me so we have a
new world that we're coming into and
it's based on the energy and if you can
read energy
you are being guided if you can't read
energy you don't know what's going to
happen next if you follow the words
that's where we have been sold a bill of
goods where people say yeah these are
good words what do you think and then
I'll buy that because the words and I
say yeah but if you ever stop long
enough to say how do you feel about it
not how what you hear about it
it empowers you beyond anything in the
world so the wake-up call now is yeah
listen to people fine but feel feel that
people feel where you are feel is this
what I want to do do I want to do this
or I want to do that I say you can ask
your head and rationalize anything but I
say don't ask that question in your head
ask the question of your heart your
heart is the monitor of the vibration
your heart will give you an answer more
accurate about anything in your world
than your rational thinking will when a
raindrop hits a pond
the ripples that come off of the
raindrop
or the shape of water
but the water was shaped by the energy
from the rock so the energy is now
visualized not the not the Ripple itself
it's the shape of the Ripple so we have
all these waves and I go so what and I
say well when you look at a pond and
it's raining out the first thing you
notice that all the ripples are
converging with each other and they're
modifying each other and that so
basically everything is connected and
everything is energy but the final shape
is really dependent on the the waves and
their patterns when they come together
some energy comes together and it
enhances power that's called construct
of interference and in human in human
terms that is good vibes yeah mainly
because you're an energy pattern and if
you're in an energy field that is in
harmony with you two energies and
Harmony come together and they ha they
add up
so that we get more power okay so there
are fields that are really good and you
can feel them Good Vibes and as I said
how what's Good Vibes I feel more power
being around you not that I'm touching
you or anything at that level because
your radiating radiating energy I'm
radiating energy but if we're radiating
harmonic energy we're in musical terms
synchrony absolutely Harmony Harmony
right and that's enhancing of power but
then there's another form of energy and
this other form of energy is uh let's
say this wave is going up and this wave
is going down when this one's going down
this one's going up so they're not in
harmony okay uh and they're interfering
and it's called destructive interference
which is the opposite of when we just
said two harmonies come together they're
interfering but it's called constructive
because there's more power but two
energies can come together in a
destructive form form and cancel out
everything
and like in technology they have
earphones that are called noise
canceling they got all this noise you
put the earphones on the noise
disappears I said what where'd the noise
going the interesting part was the
earphones have a microphone
they're recording the sound of the
environment the vibration
and then through the electronics it
plays the sound back but just out of
phase so they're not both in harmony now
one is going up and the other's going
down they're just out of phase but that
when you add up two out of phase waves
that's cancellation
to make you know uh those kind of
earphones for example noise canceling is
it's not you subtracted something from a
noise you added a noise to a noise you
added a vibration to a vibration so now
I say oh well now there's two there's a
range energies can come together and
enhance and multiply and be more
powerful
or energies that are not in harmony can
come together and cancel each other out
okay uh constructive interference
destructive interference but in human
terms is
constructive interference Good Vibes
more power and destructive interference
bad vibes there's a lot of people that
have doubts about the concept of the
influence of global meditation and
rightfully so because we've always been
programmed to ignore the invisible realm
as not being relevant to our world
but now with an understanding of quantum
physics and the role that the invisible
realm is more powerful in shaping the
Physical Realm then is the Physical
Realm itself it really adds emphasis to
the character that the energy fields in
which we live are actually shaping the
world that we experience
this is just a made-up idea that I just
said the answer is no there are
scientific studies that have shown how
meditation and groups have changed
characteristics of cities or towns in
regard to violence or love or what was
going on in the city so basically said
while meditators were in the practice of
their meditation and bringing peace to
the city it actually changed the people
in the city according to the statistics
Point did it work and answers absolutely
unfortunately when the meditators went
home the whole thing stopped point is
very simple
if we live with that spiritual activism
in our heart and use it every day then
this is not just an on and off event
this is a continuous process of shaping
the environment and the community in
which we live what we now know is the
conscious mind if you stay in the
conscious mind
you have power
but if the conscious mind is thinking it
is not using its power to interfere with
the uh to enact with the outer world
thinking is using the power to go to the
inner world so a thought is not outside
a thought is inside yeah but the
conscience is reading a thought so I
said what does that mean I said well the
conscience is helping me create this
world oh wait wait the moment I'm
thinking
I have to take that Consciousness
redirected not look out but redirect it
because thinking is inside so I said
well what does that mean I said well the
moment you were thinking you were not
creating your world at this moment I
said what does that mean I say if you're
driving the car and all of a sudden you
start thinking what it means is you're
not looking out the window anymore you
are now looking inside because answers
for thoughts are on the inside then you
go oh my God you stop looking out the
window the car is going to crash and
they go
cool apart or not yeah the subconscious
is autopilot so the moment Consciousness
is not paying attention
the subconscious Takes the Wheel
but now comes the problem the
subconscious is not you it's the program
so if I got bad driving instructions
then when the subconscious takes the
wheel as autopilot it's going to take me
down the road to ruin it's not going to
take me to where conscious says I want
to have this wonderful success but my
program is you're not worthy you're not
smart enough you're not deserving so
when that program grabs the wheel it's
not going to take me to success it's
going to take me to where the program
goes so if I disempower you in your
programming and 95 percent of your life
comes from that
the rest of your life is struggle and
it's not because you couldn't create it
it's just you didn't realize that this
subconscious guy is working 95 percent
of the time and you don't see it and
this is where how come life seems to be
a struggle from the outside coming in
when it's like oh my God you didn't get
it you're creating both success and
you're creating failure it's not coming
from outside when people gather together
and have thoughts like a meditation on
healing or peace and love that when they
come together they can influence the
world around them in fact even the
project called the global coherence
project revealed that when people come
together and start sharing awareness it
actually changes the electromagnetic
field of the earth so our thoughts are
not passive they're influencing
everything in the world in which we live
so when people come together consider
this that each person's brain is like
attuning Fork sending out thoughts and
vibration and this is revealed in the
sign Alliance of Magneto and
cephalograph most people are familiar
with something called the
electroencephalograph you put wires on a
person's head and you could read their
brain activity but a new understanding
of how to read brain activity
magnetoencephalograph the probe is out
here
this is the most profound insight for
this reason if I can read your brain
activity out here that means your brain
activity is not contained in your head
it's broadcast into the field so each of
us our brains are like tuning fork
sending out vibrations to the world each
individual has a power to their tuning
fork but as more and more individuals
come together it's an additive effect
that you have more individuals more
power and the more individuals the more
power and so as we come together in a
group
our thoughts are really being Amplified
and sending out a vibration and these
vibrations affect people who are not
even listening really because the power
of amplitude of these thoughts will
entrain people who are not even paying
attention because of this power so a
person just walking through fear will go
feels it because we're all broadcasting
this energy and this is why coming
together in a community and sharing
awareness has power a very simple point
if I go outside with my tuning fork
right now and say Let There Be Peace in
the world I'm not necessarily going to
change anything maybe not even anything
right here in the street
but if we get a large number of people
to have the same thought would change
the world and this is why it's so
important to understand the collective
nature of Consciousness that when we all
start to have Harmony we broadcast that
Harmony and the world will become in
harmony with our thoughts
we're not really feeling well is that a
physical problem or is it an emotional
chemical problem well what it turns out
that less than 10 percent of disease in
fact maybe even closer to one percent of
disease is actually connected to our
genetics and our physiology we have to
say then where is our illness coming
from and the answer is not from the
mechanism but from the Consciousness
that is driving that mechanism and this
is the relevance of the new science of
epigenetics versus the old belief called
genetics they both sound the same
genetics epigenetics but there's a
revolution and what's the difference the
belief in genetics is that when I say
this issue this illness or whatever it
is is under genetic control is the
belief that genes are actually
manifesting the problem now there's an
issue about that as far as we know we
didn't pick the genes we came with if we
don't like the characteristics we have
can't change the genes and then we're
also told that genes turn on and off by
themselves
if you put all that together you're
recognizing you're not in charge of your
life your genes are controlling your
life well that's the old belief because
the new science is called epigenetics
and it sounds the same but that Epi is a
revolution for this reason Epi means
above so for example what do we call
skin
epidermis I said what does it mean the
layer above the dermis Epi Above So I
said then what is epigenetic control
means it simply translates as this
control above the genes
what control is that Consciousness your
perception of your world is what
controls your genes and if you're not
feeling well the issue is you don't have
to change your biology you just have to
change your perception and this will
then give you your power back and this
is why we have to recognize we're not
victims of biology we are masters of our
biology patience for a simple reason
you have to have patience in
reprogramming because you're dealing
with habits that will automatically
replay themselves every time you're
trying to rewrite a habit so you have to
create a new habit it's not going to
happen the first time or the second time
but as you become aware and conscious of
it every time a negative behavior shows
up and you are becoming more conscious
you're in the power position of changing
that behavior at that moment and then
engaging in behaviors that you really
want
therefore not only does it take patience
but it takes practice so you and your
partner in a relationship have to have
the dialogue with each other when a
behavior shows up that one of the
individuals is is creating and unaware
of then the other person must say look
you perhaps didn't see what you just
said or what you just did automatic
subconscious Behavior Uh it wasn't
really the best thing and through a nice
dialogue and through practice what you
can end up is again leading to an
opportunity to engage with each other
and as a result create new programming
that supports both your wishes and
desires and aspirations and this is the
next and last step of putting that
honeymoon relationship back together
so in conclusion what can we say about
this whole honeymoon effect is this
number one people talk about mind-body
interactions and mind control in life
and while a lot of people say my mind
wouldn't have created this life
you can go back to a point where you
fell in love and recognize a very simple
truth what you created was not an
accident it was an activation of your
conscious wishes desires and aspirations
you already did create heaven on Earth
the issue is what happened to it and I
said ah the interference from the
subconscious mind if you understand the
programming and how that programming is
the default behavior and you understand
how you can rewrite that programming
then you're given an opportunity to
eliminate the negative programs in your
subconscious that have been sabotaging
you and instead replace them with
behaviors that correspond with your
wishes and desires and when you do that
the so that your conscious mind and your
subconscious mind have the same program
then guess what
at that moment whether you're paying
attention or whether you're not paying
attention you'll be engaged in the
honeymoon experience it never has to go
away The Honeymooners experience that
you could have your whole life this is
why we were here we were here to create
heaven on Earth the one time you did it
is when you fell in love
it could have stayed that way if you
understood the mechanisms we have
described here
but when you do understand the
mechanisms it says you can go back and
recreate that and make it a permanent
way of life you were born into heaven
you've experienced it once or more and
you can do it again and again and again
because that's how powerful you are you
are a Creator and you are in heaven when
you use your creation you will manifest
Heaven every day in your life and enjoy
the beauty of a living experience on
this wonderful Planet the brain is like
a tuning fork the brain works by
electrical vibration it doesn't see
things you know my eyes are sending in
information no it doesn't see light it
sees vibration sound vibration smell
vibration so the brain is a receiver
vibration but now as we know using what
is called magnetoencephalograph which is
like electroencephalograph EEG yeah it G
I put my wires on my head and I'm
recording brain activity I'm not
recording visual I'm recording
vibrations so I say oh inside the brain
there's a lot of electrical activity
vibrations which are turned into meaning
okay yeah but the new device is called
magnetoencephalograph not EEG m-e-g okay
I said what's relevant I say there's a
probe it's reading brain activity you
know what it doesn't touch the head the
probe is out here yeah I've heard you
talk about that well this becomes very
critical because basically if I'm
reading my brain function out here my
brain function is vibration yeah and
what am I reading vibration then it says
not only is my brain taking in vibration
yeah but my brain is sending out
vibration now the immediately we just
talked about construct of and
destructive interference so if a
negative vibration is coming into my
world
my brain using destructive vibrational
frequencies can cancel the negative
around me if something wonderful is
coming into my brain my brain can take
that vibration and and put it in Harmony
and then enhance the power of that
vibration yeah so the the brain has an
opportunity to cancel or enhance any
vibration in the field sorry so that
that
vibration that the brain is putting out
would you translate that to
abrasion of sound is just a different
octave but it's all sound every but
first of all I mean the hardest part
that people you know it's very difficult
for them and it was even difficult for
me even reading the book on quantum
physics is there is nothing that's
physical everything is energy and
vibration and that's very difficult for
the average person like I was to say I'm
looking at you and I said what a
beautiful physical expression and then
to find out there was no physical
expression and now it's like what the
heck does that mean and the fact is that
we read vibration yeah and so everything
is vibration in the universe and that's
the bottom line of quantum physics how
long does it take for a baby to become
independent well at least 13 years I go
yeah but what happens in the 13 years
well the parents have to help the child
grow and learn and mature so they can be
independent parents yes they have to
stay together yes at least 13 years well
how can you keep two people together for
13 years after the reproduction
Mother Nature creates the cocktail of
love the chemistry from the brain
chemistry that includes dopamine for
pleasure vasopressant for attractiveness
and oxytocin bonding bonding to that
loved one of yours for what at least 13
years so while the chemistry of Love
helps us stay together long enough to
raise our children it also adds one of
the most wonderful aspects of human life
on this planet the chemistry gives us
the concept of compassion altruism love
and harmony that distinguish humans and
this beautiful experience is worth
everything and we should honor that on
Valentine's Day and that's why my job is
to go around the world and hit people
with the dart of love and I love my job
because I start to oh there's another
couple hold on oh here we go oh whoa
good one yeah I love my job bringing oh
oh oh my God I got hit with one of my
own arrows
oh I'm so in love
Margaret
in all biological organisms there's
something referred to as the biological
imperative the biological imperative
can't be found by biologists there's no
place I say oh here it is in the south
but what it represents is the drive to
survive when we start to feel that our
life is threatened
it's not a conscious at first it's a gut
feeling it's visceral something in my
gut says something's not right this is
the biological imperative looking at
your potential future in the world that
you're living in
and what we really have to recognize is
that people are feeling it in their gut
the world is not right it's not right I
go well this is wonderful because this
is a feedback system that's saying the
world in which you live is not in
harmony with you
and therefore what it really means is
that we have to change how we influence
the world in our own way and it says
that if we start to change and send out
love instead of just receiving fear
that the love we send out has two two
aspects yes there's an external
consequence of love it influences
everyone and everything around me
there's a profoundly different chemistry
if I have a thought of love coming into
my body which you can feel when you're
in love you can feel it yes your cells
are bathing in chemistry of love but
when you have fear it's a different
chemical response it gets you girded up
for response protection Walling you off
from the outside I don't want that thing
to come in and take care of you know my
inside and I say well what's the
relevance and the answer is very simple
the chemistry released by the brain and
fear shuts down the growth mechanism of
the body shuts down the maintenance of
the body to conserve energy and the
biggest thing is there's only one
consequence and that is disease and
illness and it turns out one percent of
disease on this planet is connected to
genetics and 90 of disease or more is
lifestyle and the psychology of love and
fear
90 percent
and says
be in love
and your body will be maintained and
your immune system will be at Peak
Performance be in fear
and the game is over the brain is a
computer that's a clear fact and it has
the same functions and and systems as
our silicon conventional computer that
people is watching right now and so
here's the Insight I get a brand new
computer I got out of the store and I
pushed start and it boots up what does
that mean the screen lights up I said oh
great got a brand new computer let's do
a drawing let's do a story a spreadsheet
and say no I can't do it I say why not
you got a brand new computer you say not
until I put programs in the computer can
I use that computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs and then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like an infant can't read the book I go
no the infant brain is actually like a
video recorder it watches the mother it
watches the Father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is it real if I say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development I go the
mothers so I guess so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
rub it the fetus feels what the mother
feels if the mother is under stress and
the fetus is getting an experience that
life is very difficult up there if the
mother is feeling love and support and
everything then the life is easy for the
fetus it started learning in the last
trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is
irrelevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think on Tuesday
what am I doing on Tuesday I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought I saw
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like so why
is it relevant I go now science is
recognized 95 of the day is the average
person's amount of thinking okay so why
is it relevant well if a conscious mind
has your wishes and desires and
subconscious as your programs is your
life coming from your wishes and desires
I go up five percent
95 of your life is whatever the hell the
program you got from that seven years is
going to play and if you've got a
program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
and you know the story but I'll tell
your community I guess you have a friend
and you know your friend's behavior and
you happen to know your friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell your friend you go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say the first thing
you said how can you compare me to my
dad I'm nothing like my dad in the
audience laughs I go that's the most
profound story in the world right now
I'll tell you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like as that who's the one that doesn't
see it Bill how the hell is that
that happens when Bill is thinking let's
go the control and while he's thinking
the behavior is playing but because he's
not even looking out at his own behavior
he doesn't even see his own behavior yes
so uh in his mind no I'm not like my
identical but everybody else can see you
behave like your dad you're the only one
that can't see it and I go so why is it
relevant and the answer is simply this
we are all built we all have beliefs
wishes and desires and then we have to
say how come I'm not manifesting the
world I want how come I'm not as healthy
as I want to be how come not creating
the life I want if my mind is a Creator
and I go it is the creator but then I
tell you which mind are you operating
from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing like what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go uh didn't happen it didn't
happen and I go then what does that
person think because they're like Bill
they go oh everything's against me the
universe against me
this person is responsible that person
is responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no
all day long you were shooting yourself
in the foot with your own behavior and
you didn't even know where the gun was
coming from it was in your own hand and
I say so why is irrelevant we have been
programmed to believe that when it
doesn't work we are victims of the
outside when the truth is no 95 percent
of the day we were playing programs that
did not support us and as a result the
end of the day we didn't get that
support but we didn't see it why
subconscious was below conscious was
controlling your life your conscious
mind is I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to fall in love and I go that's
great but that's five percent of the day
yeah but 95 I go I'm coming from a
different program and so when you look
at your life and this is a beautiful
part you can say what are my programs I
just want to help people right away I'll
tell you what your programs are and you
say well how do I know I was being
programmed before I was born I was
programmed from zero to one can you tell
me what program you got when you were
zero no you didn't tell the program you
got a one no can you tell me the program
at two no about three you might say oh I
remember some things but I say you've
been essentially programmed with no
awareness of the program so you didn't
even see the program and now I say so
what is your program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to bring them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why you're working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 of the day that that
negative program is playing with five
percent effort going oh I want it to be
successful I go yeah and 95 of the day
you got what are you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and a very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as I said science has said the
first seven years you're in Theta
program
that's where you're learning then I said
but we're about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child till seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out less
than one percent of diseases connected
to genetics over 90 percent of illness
on this planet is all due to stress and
lifestyle and I say why is it relevant
because if we understood this and 90 of
illness would disappear from this planet
essentially instantaneously uh so we
have to make an understanding of how do
they connect with each other okay so
basically the understanding is this
cells have to adjust their biology for
an environment so as the environment
changes cells have to change their
biology
and the significance about that as we
mentioned very briefly is that the genes
respond to the chemistry of the blood I
go
why because the chemistry of the blood
comes from the brain I go yeah but what
chemistry comes from the brain they go
it's based on the picture held in our
mind the brain translates our pictures
into complementary chemistry so for
example the if you open your eyes and
you see someone you love the brain
translates love into wonderful healthy
chemistry a dopamine for the great
pleasure oxytocin to bond with your
lover growth hormone which this function
is exactly that I go so why is the realm
I said well people fall in love they're
happy they're excited and they're
healthy because the chemistry that comes
from a picture of Love is a chemistry
that enhances the Vitality of the cells
in contrast though if I open my eyes and
I see something that scares me I say no
love chemistry is coming out of this
brain fear chemistry comes out and I go
what is fear chemistry related to and
it's simply related to an ancient
history uh fear means we were running
away from a saber-toothed tiger back in
those days I'm not gonna say what does
Fear represent
something is chasing you something's
interfering with you something's
threatening and fear uh and stress can
come about
I'll give you a simple definition of
what stresses anything that gets in the
way of your destination whatever your
destination is if something gets in the
way of that destination it provokes
stress okay and I guess so what's
relevant about this I say let's go back
and understand what the stress response
was all about that was originally run
away from that saber-toothed tiger I go
what do you mean run away I go well you
want to save your life you better start
running immune's arms and legs and start
running and I go oh so in a state of
fear you want to use your arms and legs
I go yeah you know you hit them with
your pancreas you know the lion doesn't
care about that but if you run away
You're Gonna Make it and I go so here's
the storyline
the arms and legs are what protect you
and I say and to use them they need
blood because blood is where energy is
okay now I'm going to give you a
statement out of a physiology book and
then explain it very simply and a
statement is this when uh when a
person's in stress the blood is
preferentially sent to the arms and legs
okay yeah when I'm in stress more blood
is going to my arms and legs like I said
preferentially where was it before
I go it was in the gut I say well what's
the function of the gut
maintenance of the body fixing cleaning
repairing it takes care of Maintenance
of the body I say I say so why is it
relevant I said if you're running from a
saber-toothed tiger uh maintenance of
body is not necessary at this moment
Escape is necessary because if you don't
escape then the body is nourishment for
a tiger so uh the issue about is this
when stress hormones are released into
the system they cause the blood vessels
in the gut to squeeze shut
I go why is that because then it pushes
the blood preferentially to the arms and
legs people feel that when those blood
vessels are squeezing like this it's
called butterflies in the stomach they
feel a little queasy I go what is that
that's the closing of the blood vessels
shunting the blood off you can feel it
okay so I say oh so being chased by a
tiger I shut down the growth and
maintenance of my body to use the energy
to run away from the tiger okay
number two
the immune system uses tremendous amount
of energy I go wait a minute I said well
if you've ever really been sick you
didn't even have the energy to get out
of bed okay so if the immune system is
really engaged you're using a lot of
energy and I go well the immune system
is protecting me from an internal threat
bacterial infection okay so now I give
you this scenario you're being chased by
a saber-toothed tiger and you have a
bacterial infection
how would you split the energy between
repairing the uh the infection or
escaping the tiger I hope everyone
understands how would the bacterial
infection why if the tiger catches you
the bacteria no longer is your problem
at that moment so uh basically then it
says this
when we are under a stress from an
outside threat uh the stress hormone
shut off the immune system to conserve
energy to escape the threat and I go wow
what does that mean I said well uh it
doesn't you don't activate the immune
system because
um you need all the energy to run away
and I go well this is very critical for
a very important reason and I say well
why is it critical I say well you shut
down the immune system and a matter of
fact it's the stress hormones are so
effective at stress shutting down the
immune system
that when a person is going to receive
an organ transplant hard lungs or
whatever they give the recipient of
those organs stress hormones before the
operation but why because it prevents
the immune system from rejecting the
foreign organ right away it inhibits the
immune system so stress hormones are
used therapeutically to shut off the
immune system so I said what's the
consequence of this I say well you shut
down the growth of Maintenance about it
and shut down the immune system yeah but
it's hey if you escape the tiger it's 10
minutes you know if you escape in 10
minutes no more threat and I go then
what oh you return back into growth
again okay so I go so why is this Robin
I said well that was a long time ago
when the only stress was a damn Tiger
but today people have stressed 24 7 365
stress every day and it's dripping
stress hormones into them I say well
what's it doing I said well a couple of
things I just mentioned it's interfering
with the growth and maintenance of the
body which has to be maintained uh and I
said well what's the consequence of that
I said it's a breakdown of the system so
prolonged stress causes a breakdown of
the of the system okay number two it
inhibits the immune system so you're
more open to infections and threats from
the outside so now not only have I
weakened myself now I've made myself
more open for infection because immune
system isn't working and then I'm going
to add the last one because I called the
last one adding the insult to the injury
well you just injured yourself you're
not maintaining your body you're not
using an immune system like what else I
go
when you're in a fight or flight
situation thinking is not a good thing I
go what do you mean thinking is slow
it's a very slow process I go so what
happens I say when the stress hormones
come into the into the body they also
squeeze the blood vessels shut in the
forebrain Consciousness I said so why
would it do that I say because it pushes
the blood to the hind brain where reflex
and reactions are taken care of so let's
say you're driving a car and it starts
to go out of control guess what you're
not thinking the nut instantly your
Consciousness is shut off you're just
reflexively with a wheel and the brakes
the pedals whatever you know no thinking
I go oh
so then when we're under stress we are
less intelligent I go yes
and I go why is that relevant because
the fears that are in this world are
always compromising us to the extent
that the health care crisis is global
everywhere okay the amount of money you
spend on health care doesn't mean
anything is better the US spends the
most money on health care and it's got
the worst health statistics of any other
country and you know in the Progressive
West I go why is that relevant I say
money didn't make us any healthier the
problem we have is not the immune system
the problem we have is stress and if you
eliminate the stress then the immune
system everything comes back to order
again and I go so what what's the issue
I say
the health care crisis today has
virtually nothing to do with genes one
percent of illness that's probably about
the most 99 obviously is coming from
other where is illness coming from and
the answer is uh stress and lifestyle
the stress is what is to to prepare you
for for a threat stress says there's
something threatening you and I say well
if I'm preparing for stress that's what
we just mentioned I say if I'm not
threatened
I'm free to go outside and do anything I
want if I feel threatened I'm going to
wall myself off to protect myself put
all the goggles on the face mask and do
all our now I'm gonna be inside here and
I go you can't survive inside I'll give
a simple example when I was young we had
air raid drills in the U.S because we
thought the Russians were going to bomb
us so we built bomb shelters so I'll
give you a very simple story a city a
community is in a growth is a beautiful
day out the businesses are working the
kids are in school so this community is
is growing and doing well an air raid
siren goes off what does everybody do
they stop work where do they go they go
under the ground into the air raid
shelter I say then why I said well
nothing's happening now everything's
shut down okay like oh yeah and I say
then what I say well in 10 or 15 minutes
all clear
we get out of the bomb shelter everybody
goes back to work so it was like a you
know half hour Interruption during the
day where we were growing then we spent
a half hour in protection and then we
came out of protection and went back to
work again everything was Pro no problem
here's the problem
the air raid siren goes off you go into
the bomb shelter and there is no all
clear
I said what does that mean I said well
you can't come out of the bomb shelter I
said until what I said you can't come
out until it's all clear I said when's
it all clear so it's not getting all
clear I said how long can I live in the
bomb shelter I see not very long why how
much food did you put in there how much
water do you have in your bomb shelter
and the point is you'll use up those
resources and if you don't come out you
will die in the bomb shelter when we're
in stress we go into the bomb shelter
psychologically WE wall ourselves off
we're safe inside here and I say how
long can you survive inside the bomb
shelter I say a short period of time was
no big deal
but as you extend the time my life
becomes threatened and this covet crap
is going around and extending the fear
on and on and on again we're having a
second Spike I go
big deal I mean normal right why have a
predictable how come I have a second
Spike I said if you take the susceptible
people and you move them into a
quarantine so they're not exposed to the
virus and they're healthy in their room
but I say then you say quarantine over
and you come out I go did the virus go
away no that's still there are you still
susceptible of course you are you didn't
get any immune reaction in the bomb
shelter over there I say so what do you
think would happen if you let that group
of people you put away back out I go
they'll get infected just like the first
group of people and guess what it's
called a spike I go of course it's a
spike you took them out of the program
you put them back into the show they get
to see and then you say the second Spike
I go did you not expect a second Spike
and what reason why would there not be a
second Spike there you didn't lose the
virus you didn't gain any immune to some
you know precaution against it you just
opened up the next population yeah here
we are in the second Spike of course
that's exactly what would happen if you
take the population and put it away and
then think well okay now they can come
back out I said you didn't change
anything they're just out now the second
Spike so so all of this stuff and I go
so you want to know what I believe the
biggest problem the whole thing is
because I see it as a manipulation of
information and that is this
people have power when they're in a
community
people have no power when there is no
community and the covid system broke
Community all over the world at once
everybody went to their room
I go and what power do you have I say
absolutely no power people lost all the
power in the world except for those that
were manipulating what was going on
outside of that room and that was a way
of disempowering an entire damn
population of this planet with the fear
they said go hide in your room because
you can't gather together you can't have
an opinion together no you can stay in
your room and you stay in your room and
all of a sudden I say oh my God that's
the biggest problem in the whole world
you've isolated people and when you've
done that you've removed their ability
to have power perception can rewrite the
genetic code
when you're under stress you will
rewrite your genes it's built into every
one of your cells you have genetic
engineering genes the function of these
genes is if you find stress that the
body cannot seem to get out of the body
will make an effort to change its
structure to get out of the problem
and of course the issue is this what if
your perception wasn't real and you
change your genes now you're in deep
doo-doo and we now find a very important
fact
95 percent of cancer has no genetic
linkage
95 percent of cancer is a response of
the individual cells to their
experiencing life
and if you change your experiences you
can change the presence of that cancer
that's how it works why does stress
cause so much disease I'll tell you why
stress you're running away from that
saber-toothed tiger whatever's
threatening you and I say what is stress
anything that gets in the way of where
you want to go is a stressor I say so
why is that relevant I go because that's
like in the mind the Sabertooth tiger
and you want to run that's what fight or
flight and I said but you use your arms
and legs I go yeah but that I need the
energy I said the blood carries the
energy so I say so what when the stress
hormones come into the body you want the
body to put the blood into the arms and
legs because you're going to have to run
that's what fear and stress is about
okay so what do you mean put it isn't it
in the arms of life cycle yeah but most
of the blood is in your gut I say what's
the gut all the organs of Maintenance
take care of your health fix the blood
if you know aerate clean all that stuff
I go yeah but when you're in stress I
don't need to take care of myself I got
to run away from the tiger so stress
hormones number one shut off the blood
vessels in the gut and I said that's
like butterflies in the stomach when you
feel that fear that's the stress
hormones causing the blood vessel
squeeze I said so why would you do that
because then the blood is pushed to the
arms and legs that's where most of the
energy is needed that's number one so
you compromise Health just by having
stress hormones because you're shutting
it off the maintenance but number two
the immune system uses a lot of energy
that's why when people are sick
sometimes they can't even get out of bed
I say so if I'm being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger and I got a
bacterial infection how do I want to you
know split the energy and I go the hell
with a bacterial infection that
saber-toothed tiger catches you bacteria
is not your problem anymore so guess
what stress hormones by function shut
down the immune system and I go and it's
so effective that when doctors want to
transplant a foreign organ into a
recipient and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject the
foreign organ before they do the
transfer they give the recipient stress
hormones to shut off the immune system
so it doesn't reject the foreign organ I
say this stress hormones are so
effective at shutting it off they use it
therapeutically to shut it off and I go
why is it relevant because our entire
world is in such stress all the time
that they're dripping stress hormones
and I say what are they doing they're
shutting off the growth and maintenance
of the body they're shutting down the
immune system I say net result illness
and death from stress and that is why up
to 90 percent of illness comes from
stress because the chemistry of [ __ ] of
stress redirects your energy to run not
to be conscious and aware and healthy
take care of yourself I say what do you
mean first of all take care of your
system it will manage this virus without
killing you but first of all you have to
make sure your blood has proper
nutrition you need to be healthy in the
system and our diet is so compromised
within oh yeah food and garbage food
that I have to tell people you've got to
go back and eat natural you have to go
back and eat organic because industrial
Farm stuff is filled with chemistry that
is is causing you more problems
number two take vitamins and supplements
why especially vitamin C and vitamin D
these enhance the immune system lots of
vitamin C Way Beyond whatever
relationship you met Linus Pauling yes
interesting because I lectured at his uh
Institute when I was at Stanford wow and
it was interesting because the science
has revealed that massive doses I take
two grams of vitamin C every morning
high five
and the relevance about that is I'm also
you know I'm what am I trying to do
de-stressing I'm not stressed I live in
another world I walk out the door I
don't live in that world of the people
around me they're the ones that are
stressed I'm like I'm not stressed I'm
okay I'm 76 am I afraid because I'm old
[ __ ] it's oh BS belief system excuse
me uh uh that um I'm not afraid to go
outside
I I eat well I take vitamins and
supplements hey
do work exercise something to keep the
body moving because that enhances the
Vitality of the circulatory system which
is delivering immune function so eat
well vitamin supplements you exercise
and number four most important do not
put the fear in your head
because the function of the mind is to
manifest whatever you believe and if you
start to believe in the fear then the
function of the mind is to manifest that
fear and that's why the whole idea is
shut off the damn TV and don't listen to
these people because they are
disempowering you
with fear and fear is where you lost
your power because once you do fear as
you shut yourself off and you can't shut
yourself off we are connected to a world
you can't live in a bubble you'll die
and the idea is if you buy the fear you
are putting up walls around you because
you want to protect I'm protecting here
I say walls are the opposite of growth
growth you have to open yourself put
things in okay and uh and fear as you
shut everything down there's something
called resonance when something vibrates
at the same vibration they enhance their
power so two instruments are playing at
the same vibration that vibration is
more Amplified okay uh but here's the
point why does a patient come to a
doctor and the answer is because we have
been programmed to believe that's our
source of healing they never said what
the doctor had to do when you were a kid
oh you're sick we go to the doctor
remember nobody told you what a doctor
would do what did you learn that the
doctor provides provides whatever it is
so we give up power over our life
because that doctor is a professional
what the hell do I know I'm just as an
average person so when it comes to a
truth which is my conscious and
subconscious mind when it comes to a
truth I give up power to the doctor
so if the doctor has got a lot of energy
and everything is energy that's a whole
different I wish we had another hour I'd
talk about that but uh the illusion of
matter that that's uh that's we look
like everything is physical and quantum
physics as a scientist says no
everything is energy so I say when a
person who is an energy source goes to a
doctor who is an energy source
the healing comes from the doctor having
a higher energy a higher more powerful
energy so when I walk into the doctor's
office just walking into the doctor's
office all of a sudden I feel a
different energy because that's the
person that knows and I don't and I say
so why is a relevant I said if a doctor
goes in not having a good day and
chiropractors know this they they can
practice for years and then sometimes
they go in and the whole day is crappy
adjustments and it's like it's not
working well I say what you forget how
to do an adjustment you've been doing it
30 years no they came in with their own
mind not being in harmony whether they
had a fight with their spouse or their
financial issues like oh why is it
relevant a person that came in for the
healing came in for the extra energy
that the Healer was going to give them
but if the Healer themselves have broken
energy because of the stresses and
there's all that when the patient comes
in the doctor has no powers very much
and that's why they realize geez my
adjustments didn't work and I've been
doing it all these years I go you didn't
forget how to do adjustment but when
you're touching somebody that's called
Hands-On healing
and if you're putting in energy that's
less than the energy of the patient yeah
then the energy of the patient comes
down instead of going up the physician
heal thyself meaning before you go in
there and deal with a patient they came
in for your energy and if your energy is
not up to a higher level then you can't
boost their energy you can only boost it
if your energy is higher and so the
physician the Healer the nurse more
important because they're even the ones
I'm more importantly are the more
dialogue connected to the patient than
than a lot of Physicians who hardly even
notice what's going on but it's nurses a
lot in the age that are doing a lot of
the healing why
they have the energy they spend more
entanglement time sure and and therefore
that's really interesting so what is
healing I say raising the energy the
vibration energy is life no energy death
high energy a lot of life is the
physician the Healer the nurses the
attendant are they offering more energy
than the patient has if they do then
you're lifting the health of that
patient I'll leave with this because
it's so profoundly important in our
world today and that is this apparently
presumably one of the last things Jesus
said when in the crucifixion was father
forgive them they know not what they do
and I go we have to recognize that every
human
is is a spiritual entity but also a
program
and we have to recognize that they are
not their program that's been foist upon
them
and that somebody has a bad program and
we get into the uh like this I say you
have to learn to forgive them because
they themselves like Bill Bill didn't
know he's behaving like his dad they
don't know it either and so the idea is
that word that that phrase applies to
each one of us to move into the future
and that is recognize that everyone is a
spiritual entity but a lot of people
have some bad programs does that make
them a bad person I go it makes a bad
program for sure do I have to hang
around with them because they got bad
programs they know but do I have to hate
them no
because they don't even know what the
hell they're doing and all of a sudden
it says this forgiveness
of people doesn't mean you have to be
with them you know they want to play
that program fine you do it over there
I'm over here but you have to recognize
is it them or their program
and then when you recognizes then that's
where that quote comes important forgive
them they don't Bill didn't know what
the hell he was doing and we are all
built we're all built by the way we are
polluting the atmosphere and destroying
the ecosystem we are aggravating climate
change we're exacerbating climate change
so we are indeed involved and the
significance about it is this climate
changes are most immediate problem on
this planet of course you've seen the
pictures of seawater Rising with melting
ice caps and thinking that's where the
big problem comes from and yet on a
positive note let us recognize a simple
fact human civilization is the most
adaptable of all organisms on this
planet the question we ask now is will
we learn to adapt when climate change is
a continuous process and we cannot
depend on growing food to support the
population the takeaway message of all
this quantum physics stuff is simply
this is that we are energy we're in
tangle with a whole field of energy the
whole universe is one interconnected
whole and this is how we are connected
to each other however during our
developmental programming we get beliefs
that are programmed into us by our
parents through our culture and then
these beliefs then become the reality
that we experience historically we
Define our populations based on
separateness separate on Race religion
origin of country it's a separateness
that divides the population an
interesting point that evolution is
actually the unification of everyone
come together in harmony then we have to
recognize the programming of separation
is the divisive nature that is
preventing us from evolving into the
future at this time I'd like to to show
you through an illustration the
simplistic nature of what's happening to
us and I'll say here are three cells
where did these cells come from they
came from the environment through a
process of evolution all coming from the
very same Source well this is when
programming begins and look what can
happen you can program one child to be a
Christian you can program an identical
twin of that child to be a Muslim or
another one of the same children to be a
Jewish child this is separation is a
separation of who they really are I say
no you can't separate that we all came
from the same Source what we have to
recognize is it's the programming that
places the separation so many people
think when you die you go to a place
called Heaven I go you didn't understand
we were born into heaven this is where
we came to create this is where we came
to experience if you lose the body and
go out there you have Consciousness
that's really great I'm not saying it's
not but here's the opportunity to what
to manifest make something do something
experience some thing if you then decide
I'm going to do it metaphor metaverse I
go well then you wasted all these
beautiful receptors that were designed
to to have those wonderful experiences
to manifest them for real more powerful
they can do more work with heaven and
yet for most people to tell I go is it
hell because you can't you know because
it's the bad place I say no it's hell
because your program that you got took
away your creativity
and programmed you to be the victim in a
world that you're actually creating so
as a victim you can create a world of
being a victim
and your ideas yeah but if you're a
master then you can create the world of
being a master you are a great example
of it yeah I I you did driving then you
created uh the wine and then you had the
Cosmetics or the candles and all that
other you know that all that stuff you
you took your mind and took it out and
made creativity what is heaven what did
you want what is Heaven is a is a
definition of what you want I said do
you have to die to get what you want to
say no matter of fact it's easier to get
what you want when you're alive because
this is where you can do it so the big
joke is everyone's thinking oh when I
die I'm gonna go to heaven and I'm going
Jesus your whole missed the experience
man it was here is where you created are
you creating Heaven are you creating
hell that was a creation
uh and the idea is if you own it
like you've done like I've done like the
people that you've interviewed on your
program
they have taken over ownership of their
creation
and they're creating the life that they
want and most other people are saying oh
this is against me and my genes aren't
good and this world and that and I'm a
victim and I go
sorry folks you missed the opportunity
to create next time you come back you'll
figure it out maybe that's interesting
because all the people that are here
are in what is called Evolution yeah
everyone thinks oh Evolution takes
millions of years ago no that was the
old version because the conversion shows
that Evolution builds up and then some
cataclysmic event drops it and it builds
up again another cataclysmic event drops
that these are called mass extinctions
five of them have already occurred the
last one when the dinosaurs were here
the planet was lush tropical forest
dinosaurs and everything a comet a big
one hit near Mexico
across the Web of Life to Come Undone
all that what happened 75 of all living
things disappeared including the
dinosaurs that was the last mass
extinction today we're in mass
extinction number six and science that
says well what's causing this one and
the answer is our behavior is destroying
ourselves and the environment the
illness said this the the planet is has
got a Health crisis everywhere
in other words when we are able to
collectively change our Behavior we can
avoid the massive the six by 16
Extinction that's the only choice we
have
and it will work and who will be left
the ones that let go of the old
structure and said I will now put my
life energy into building a new
structure so we have I use the story of
um a caterpillar uh that turns into a
butterfly a caterpillar is a voracious
it eats everything it you put a
caterpillar on a plant eat all the
leaves off the plant then I say then
what I say well when the food runs out
it goes into a a chrysalis a pupa a
cocoon a cocoon and then comes out a
butterfly I say the butterfly has the
lightest touch it doesn't even touch the
plant it's flying most of the time the
verb the caterpillar is voracious eating
up African I say human civilization is
in a caterpillar mode we are heating up
the environment we're destroying the
environment and everything like this I
say but there's a point where we have to
go into the Cocoon I say why you can't
live this way anymore I say now here's
where the issue that we just talked
about
a caterpillar comes in a butterfly comes
out I go but the cells of the
caterpillar which are like miniature
people when the caterpillar was eating
and eating it all up all the cells were
working the muscle cells the digestion
cells everybody's working all the cells
are working no more food
well there's no more digestion so what
about the digestion cells oh they lose
their job because it's no more food what
about the muscle cells no we're not
moving anymore there's no place to go
and the muscles I say the community of
cells in the caterpillar break down make
a soup a soup of cells and then what and
here comes the important part
some of the cells are called imaginal
cells
and they have a vision of a different
organization a vision of a butterfly
so what's happening is the caterpillar
cells are breaking down the community
but the imaginal cells are taking those
cells and selling wait we've built
something better we build the butterfly
civilization is is destroying the planet
we can't do it anymore so it says what
you have the transformation you have to
go metamorphosis you have to change from
the voracious human civilization into a
civilization that has a light touch on
the planet and so I say so what it means
I say well in the Cocoon some cells are
breaking down some cells are being built
I say which which one do you want to be
with I say don't hold on to the one
breaking down because it's going to
break down let go of one that's breaking
down put your energy your effort your
action into building the better one that
was coming and so we're in the middle of
this chaos
which is coming down and being built up
and I said your health and your futures
depended on which one of these you want
to hold on to you want to hold on to the
caterpillar you're going to die because
the caterpillar is death
and the Butterfly is life and so we're
facing at this moment with the breakdown
the jobs are being lost the economy is
crashing the whole world is in a shaky
okay in this moment of shaking you have
a choice
and I say unfortunately too many people
oh I want the old one the old one give
it back to me the old one I said the old
one is the problem
and you gotta let go and I say you got
to have Harmony I get worse Army I go
vibration what's vibration I go music
you you're creating thoughts or
vibration that's when they put wires on
your head they read it called the
electroencephalogram they're reading
your mind I said what are they reading
vibration
I say so if you change the vibration
change the mind you get another world
and therefore vibration is the key
element of quantum physics
that determines if we're going to build
something or we're going to take
something down depends on the vibration
I mean the first step the first one was
so small and Irrelevant in one sense but
so powerful was I'm working on this
going oh my God I I've been programmed
and if I if I follow the program it's a
good program great but if it's a bad
program I'm going downhill uh and I
remember I was in my office at the
University and one of my faculty
colleagues came in that day and said
okay Bruce what are you bringing to the
faculty party on Saturday night you know
what I want to tell you faculty party
might as well just kill yourself you go
there and everybody's sitting around
with a drink not talking to each other
because they don't really like it
okay and I thought about that and I
thought I work all damn week
why should I go to a stupid faculty
party and waste the entire time where I
had freedom to create something I would
love to do so on you know just came
right on my mind oh I'm sorry I didn't
realize it was this weekend I have other
plans I can oh I can't I can't go this
weekend I didn't have plans but I just
said that and he looked at me like
you're not going to The Faculty party I
go no and he walked out and the moment
he walked out he went oh
I just got Saturday night for me I can
do what I want on Saturday night and I
started to say what's next and it lined
up what can I get rid of that I've been
programmed that this is what we do
socially even though it takes away
character quality joy out of life and I
started to eliminate them
and say wait I'm creating this I don't
want to give up my creation because
socially this is what we should do I
said I got my life man I want to live it
and I have been living a heaven on Earth
life
ever since those days why well with the
help of my partner Margaret who I met at
50 so 40 is a kid's age at 50. uh uh and
she she was quite aware of all the stuff
that I talked about we changed we
rewrote our programs beautiful and we
put together what 26 years now oh my God
a honeymoon every day I wake up hey I'm
still alive I've got a great partner we
have a great life I work every day I
wake up it's like wow I'm still here I'm
enjoying every day that I can get it's
called the honeymoon effect
forever wow how'd you do that I say get
rid of the programs that took the joy
away and replace them with programs that
give you Joy there's Bruce Lipton has
two two lives Bruce Lipton the guy who
lives in the house and goes to the store
and all that stuff okay and Bruce within
the scientist I go what's the difference
I said Bruce lived in a scientist knows
that from science we are facing our own
extinction because of our own human
behavior Bruce Lipton as a scientist
also knows this if you want to create a
world that we can live in and sustain
ourselves and be healthy we have to
change our Behavior because our behavior
is causing the problem so I also know
what does this mean it says the
structure has to break
to build a better structure a new
civilization because the foundation of
this civilization is creating all the
problems it's the culture and the way we
live with fear and hate and violence and
all that I go a garden which we came
from a garden is the height of
cooperation and we we live in the height
of of war and violence and all this
stuff we live in competition and the
idea is this then the belief system of
this civilization the fear the
competition the war all that stuff
that's part of our creation because
we're creating this physics
let's say you want to change the world
you got to change the creation and we
have to break this structure because the
structure is perpetuating the problem
yes and it has to go in a chaos phase
let's break down yeah that's right so
science Bruce goes yep it has to break
down because that's how we're going to
build a new one and then Bruce the guy
who lives here goes what a mess it's a
little crazy mess this is scary
I'm living in Crazy mess but then Bruce
Lipton science comes in and says you
have to do this because the way you have
been living is causing the problem you
have to change
and that's easy to say but if you're out
there in the world as a working person
and everything and you have to
experience it's like it's falling apart
I go that scares people scares people
stress hormones stress hormones stop
thinking and listen to whatever they
said on a TV or the web don't think shut
down your your health why because I'm
running from that tiger because I am
scared and the point is then the health
issues got worse just watching the news
you walk away with a stress hormones
coming in they're like oh you just all
of a sudden made your system worse
because the stress hormones are going to
compromise you the things that you wish
for desire want in your life and you
have to work hard sweat over it I'm
putting a lot of effort in I'm gonna
make I'm gonna work I'm working on it
and I go why are you working so hard
is beautiful because whatever that
destination is you don't have a program
to support it and you're trying to
override a habit that doesn't give you
what you want by putting more effort
into it and I go good idea not good
process why 95 of your life is coming
from the program uh and five percent
from this little conscious mind up here
cannot mathematically if you think about
the subconscious of the million times
more powerful programmer than the
conscious mind I say and you want to
write override the subconscious I go boy
that's a [ __ ] that's not gonna work
very well uh and yet there are ways to
do it because if it didn't this is going
to be a lousy interview but there are
ways to rewrite it and the idea about it
is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life and change the
outcome you can change these programs
sometimes in 15 minutes or less okay but
you need to know how to do it okay uh
the relevance about all this is um uh uh
the movie The Matrix uh it's all of
Science Fiction I go no no no movie The
Matrix is a documentary what do you mean
I go premise everybody's been
programming go oh that's a given we are
all programmed from last trimester to
age seven everyone is but in the movie
they say well you can take a red pill
and get out of the program
and I want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed okay when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love I go what do you mean I go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later oh life is so
beautiful I'm so in love I'm so happy
look I'm glowing look I got growth
hormone in my system I go 24 hours later
after blah blah blah all those years and
24 hours later you manifest heaven on
Earth I go how'd that happen and the
answer is beautiful because the answer
is when you fall in love you stop
thinking you stay present it's called
staying mindful like what does that mean
I say when you're thinking is when the
subconscious autopilot kicks in if
you're not thinking then the conscious
creative mind is the one that's
manifesting your life so I go the moment
you fell in love why would you think and
the reason is this you've been waiting
for this person your whole life they
showed up you want to think and
disconnect from this I go no you want to
stay present you want to be mindful you
want to be there like oh you stop
thinking I said what's the result
it's the red pill the moment you stop
thinking is you're not diverting to the
subconscious anymore you are operating
from conscious wishes and desires and so
the honeymoon is not an accident it's a
manifestation that says I'm not playing
the program you're being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger I say you you need
energy to to survive you have to run I
said where's the energy going to go I
said well Energy's in the blood that's
what carries the energy I say when the
stress hormones come in because the
tiger is chasing you
it does several things it shuts off the
blood flow to the the gut the viscera
that's not all the organs pancreas
stomach intestines I go it shuts off the
blood supply I say why I don't need to
fix and maintain the body if the tiger
is going to catch me and then I don't
that's a waste of my energy I want all
the energy go to my arms and legs Escape
so I say stress hormones shut off the
the mechanism of the viscera the growth
and maintenance of the body while you're
being chased
I said what else and here comes the one
that you were bringing up when when
we're really sick
you don't have a lot of energy to even
get out of bed because the immune system
uses a lot of energy to keep you healthy
I go so I'm being chased by a tiger
and I have a bacterial infection so I'm
putting energy in to run away and
putting energy into the infection I go
why do you worry about the infection
because if the tiger catches you the
infection is not a problem anymore
you're done okay so the this is the
point you brought up and this is the
most important point for the audience to
understand
stress hormone shut off the immune
system so that the energy can be used to
run away from the tiger before being
used to fight the bacteria
and this is the most important
understanding because stress is the
cause of over 90 percent of illness on
this planet everyone thinks genes are
causing the illness I go less than one
percent of illnesses connected to genes
ninety percent of illness is stress
because when you put the stress hormones
in what do they do they shut off the
maintenance of the body they shut off
the immune system and they even shut off
the intelligence
if the conscious brain the one up in the
front that's connected to you your
person is a slow processor like a slow
computer
the subconscious is like a super fast
computer
if you're being chased by a tiger it's
not the time to think of oh oh
oh I go no no run and so the stress
hormone shut down the blood vessels in
the forebrain where the Consciousness is
pushes the blood with the energy to the
hindbrain where reflexes and reaction no
thinking because thinking is slow so I
say so then stress hormones do three
things number one they shut off the
growth and maintenance of the body
number two they shut down the immune
system which protects you from internal
problem and number three they make you
less intelligent
look at the look at the world today the
stress levels are overriding as I said
90 percent of illness is straight stress
not genetics it's lifestyle it's the
fear it's not living in harmony they
don't have enough good music to bring
Harmony into their world they're they're
on edge
I go well that automatically compromises
your health humans
have morality
we're supposed to anyway you know don't
kill things okay uh we're supposed to
have morality
but corporations have no morality they
just have a mission how much money can I
make that is the mission by law of what
a corporation is so I say then that's
why they can do anything let's destroy
the environment if we can make enough
money
and all of a sudden you start to see the
leadership of this world is not really
caring about what the individuals want
they want to appease the money making
part and then the laws come down and uh
and if the if it conflicts with a
corporate law then screw the people
let's give the corporation their due and
that's once we gave up and we said
humans are like uh corporations are like
humans and have the power of a human I
go no they don't they have no morality
they're nothing like a human at all uh
and uh and we gave them all the power
and this is a wake-up call for all of us
that said
who's caring for you
you know I love it they always talk
about the friendly Banker
when's the banker friendly the banker is
friendly when you have money yeah if you
don't have money Bankers not so friendly
anymore doesn't care about you at all
you know and I go same thing
pharmaceutical company you got money
we're working with you yeah I don't care
about you if you have no money and we
lost and so the evolution we're facing
right now says we have been driven to
this by a Minds that have no uh care for
an environment they take what you want
do what you want throw crap into the
water you know all this kind of stuff
dig out the natural resources every it's
like
what's our future if you do this the
answer is it's already happening
Extinction we're not in harmony with
each other obviously and we're not in
harmony with nature
and I say well that you got two choices
here
follow the money
or follow the Harmony
and right now unfortunately this is a
tug of war and corporates are winning
because fear because once you're afraid
you give up power fear is a definition
I'm not I'm afraid like well then who's
going to help you who's got the biggest
stick yeah who's the one with the
biggest clown let's give them the power
and I'll wait here for them to fix it
and I go
they're clubbing you over that at this
point uh and we have to wake up I'm
sorry I went on a tirade
an adult has all different ranges of
vibrations of brain function but when a
child is born for the first two years it
has a very low vibration called Delta
and a child is in Delta well adults when
they're in Delta that's called sleeping
well yeah for the first year and a half
or two of a child's life they spend most
of their time in Delta so that's a
predominant vibration of a child's brain
but around two years of age the
vibration of a child's brain increases
at a higher level of vibration and this
level is called Theta well Theta that's
characterized by imagination and that's
true a child between the ages of two and
seven is mixing the real world and the
imaginary world at the same time so for
example the child is on a broom
pretending it's a horse well to that
child that broom is a horse so if the
mother says give me the Broom the child
looks at her like what are you talking
about because the child really
experiences that as a broom oh on the
old famous tea party where they pour
nothing into the cup and they drink
nothing and they go that was the best
tea I ever had well mixing imagination
in the real world is what happens
between ages two and seven when a child
is experiencing Theta but by time the
child reaches seven the vibration goes a
little bit higher and we call that
vibration Alpha and Alpha is calm
Consciousness well that's the child's
life in the beginning of Consciousness
very peaceful and loving but then around
age 12 the vibration goes up even higher
now it's called beta vibration well beta
vibration is the brain activity when a
child is in school or when an adult is
working
and the Beautiful part about this is
every year of the child's life the
vibrations get greater and greater and
then when we're adults we have the whole
range yes at night when we're sleeping
it's Delta and just in the morning
before we wake up call Twilight reverie
the brain kicks into a higher vibration
Theta and then as the alarm clock goes
off and we're ready to wake up the brain
is now an alpha calm Consciousness for
the morning and then on the way to work
the vibration even gets higher now it's
called beta and at work all day long
that's a very high functioning
Consciousness beta you know the
interesting part though is when you come
back home it goes back in Reverse so you
come home from work and you've been
working all day you're in beta and then
when you get home you start to calm down
and relax and the vibration slows down
the alpha calm Consciousness and then
guess what the moment you fall asleep
and your eyes close the brain is now in
a lower vibration Theta and then as you
go a little deeper guess what Delta and
you're in sleep and every day this Cycle
Works Delta Theta Alpha Beta coming home
beta Alpha Theta Delta cycling and
cycling well this is really a very
interesting aspect of brain function for
this reason
Theta the brain activity between two and
seven years old for a child is not just
imagination Theta is hypnosis
and this is how a child can download so
much information as a little kid under
seven years of age when we understand
the nature of the progression of our
brain vibration it then becomes
important for parents to know this for a
very important reason when does a child
start to actually downloading Behavior
well very interesting fact even before
the child is born and the last trimester
of pregnancy the brain is already
beginning to hit on Theta and when it's
doing that the child is experiencing
what the mother's experience so a happy
mother is sending happy information to
the baby as programs but a mother who is
afraid frightened not sure of the world
she's living in sounds kind of scary
messages to that feed it says it's
developing and the child is actually
beginning to download these messages the
mother is Head Start program she's the
one that sees the world and her
interpretation of the world is
translated into programs into the baby
even before it's born and why should
they be able to download So Much
Information well think about it this way
how many rules must a child learn to be
a functional member of a family and then
how many more rules must that child
learn to be a functional member of the
community thousands of rules if you
think about it for example how a father
talks to his own child is different than
how the father talks to the neighbor's
child which is different than how the
father talks to the mother which is
different than how the father talks to
the neighbor's wife and that's even
different than how the father talks to
the policeman you got to learn a lot of
rules to grow up and be a functional
member of a family and community and the
idea of can you teach this to a child a
youngster that can't read They're going
to go to school no they're kids so the
most important Insight is that a child
between the age of two and seven is
observing the community so it's
important for us to all recognize that
around children we really must be
behaving at our best and highest level
because we are now programming the
future of that child the problem is this
when we grow up 95 of our life is coming
from the programs that we downloaded
starting even before we were born
through age seven and these kids when
they grow up are going to be the world
that we're moving into these kids are
our future so it really isn't coming
upon us to recognize this we should be
helping them with the best behavior we
must be on our best behavior because
they are copying our Behavior between
ages two and seven especially and
therefore if we want the future to be
better then we have to be better people
as parents as Community as family we
have to be the models that we want these
kids to be because they're watching us
they're recording us and they'll become
us it's really interesting to understand
the difference in the dichotomy between
living in love and living fear and it's
best Illustrated if I put cells in a
Petri dish and I put nutrients in front
of the cells the cells will move to the
nutrients but if I put toxins in front
of the cells the cells move away from
the toxins the significance is when
you're in a growth situation which is
really what love represents you're open
because growth is open to the world and
you assimilate things and that's where
growth comes from protection is just a
complete opposite protection means
you're threatened your life is
threatened and you wall yourself off in
protection so growth is open and
protection is closed well the relevance
is then you can't be in growth and in
protection at the same time so in our
normal history of biology protection is
a necessary part of our survival you
being chased by a sabertooth tiger you
seriously have to do something about
this so what Nature has done is created
a protection mechanism
in scientific terms is referred to as
the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
very complicated abbreviated as HPA and
what this really represents is the
hypothalamus the part of the brain that
does an interpretation it looks at the
world and says am I in a safe place or
am I in a scary place if the
hypothalamus sees that we're in threat
of any kind it sends a signal to the
pituitary gland the master gland whose
signals coordinate the activity of 50
trillion cells well in the case of a
threat the pituitary gland releases
hormones that activate the adrenal
glands the adrenal system is referred to
as fight or flight
so it's basically a protection mechanism
so I say okay great the HPA axis
hypothalamus sees the threat pituitary
coordinates 50 trillion cells and the
adrenal gland prepares for a protection
response well if you're being chased by
a saber-toothed tiger you're going to
have to use your arms and legs to run
away or fight what you need to do so the
system when under threat releases stress
hormones from the adrenal gland the
adrenal gland allocates all the energy
of the system to run away from the
saber-toothed tiger well that means the
first thing the adrenal gland activity
does is cause the blood vessels in the
gut to constrict this forces the blood
which has the energy to the arms and
legs but then you have to realize this
the moment you shut down the blood
vessels of the gut this is where growth
and maintenance and the necessary
control and stability of the body is
coming from the organs of the viscera so
when you're in a moment of threat you
shut down the energy going to this gut
as you're allocating the energy to run
away that's one of the first things that
happens as we shut down growth and
maintenance of the body and people say
well growth I'm an adult I don't need to
grow it I go if we're made out of 50
trillion cells but every day we lose
billions hundreds of billions of cells
numbers that are just too big to
conceive of actually a normal attrition
aging damage and so basically it says
every day you're losing hundreds of
billions of cells that means by
definition every day you have to replace
hundreds of billions of cells so while
you don't see yourself growing every day
you are growing to match what you're
losing so if you shut down the growth of
the system it won't take very long for
the system to become in a state of
disrepair because if you're not
maintaining the replacement of those
cells this will lead to sickness and
disease and number two remember when the
threat is present the adrenal hormones
are released and stress they shut down
the immune system and this is an effort
to conserve energy to run away from the
tiger what's the result of being in a
state of protection the answer is you
shut down the growth and maintenance of
the body and you shut down the immune
system both of these if sustained for a
period of time will inevitably lead to
disease and death
and just to refer back again to the
nature why Evolution gave us this
protection response to run away from the
saber-toothed tiger but once you run
away from it once you've made it away
from that tiger
then the system goes back into growth
again so by Nature's understanding
you're only supposed to use the stress
system for very short intervals of time
because it interferes with the normal
functions and then you look at today's
world and we realize 24 7 365 stress
hormones are being released into the
system we read the newspapers we watch
the news we're concerned about the world
and it's unfolding so what was supposed
to be only used for a very short time
has now become chronic and The Chronic
release of stress hormones has resulted
in an elevation of the amount of disease
and sickness that our planet of this
experience experiencing right now so the
significance is we must recover and then
to recover it says we must get out of
the fear that we live in because fear
kills
I am the happiest of guys now but it
took me almost like 50 years to really
get there uh and and the fact let's go
back well when I was in the 40s that was
like 80s 1980s and I was working on stem
cells and teaching people what most
people still believe that the genes that
we inherit really determine the
character of our lives and that becomes
uh when you think about it it's like
well did you pick the genes you came
with and we come nothing I know of uh
can you change the genes if you don't
like the characteristics no and then we
tell you on top of that is oh the jeans
turn on and off by themselves so you
could be walking down the street and the
Jane goes oh time for cancer is like
what and then I say what is what were we
teaching what what were we teaching to
Medical people as well as the public is
that we were victims of heredity that
things were running in our family and
then that would determine the character
of Our Lives and then the fear
associated with that is oh my God you
know like uh Angelina Jolie for example
had a double mastectomy because the fear
of breast cancer of her mother dying
from it and her grandmother of course I
put into her mind that she would be a
next victim of that and then she has a
double mastectomy to say I will prevent
this from happening which is well that's
not really true but what was the point
it was the fear
and the fear of being a victim meaning
you're powerless and I go this is what
people believe about their health I am
powerless uh uh we got programmed when
we were children to recognize when it
comes to health we don't take care of
that we go to the specialist the doctor
I said what is what is that learning
period in our first seven years what
does that do with programs I say yeah
but what's the program and the program
is I'm not in charge of my health uh
that when it comes to health issues I
have to go see another person and then
their truth becomes my truth because who
am I uh and I said so what's the
consequences I say you first thing you
just gave up power over your health you
say I won't take care of my health I'm
going to let that professional that's
that's my program and I go well there's
a problem
and the problem is
as I was learning and then attributing
my life to programs that I didn't know I
had because that was before I knew about
the seven years of programming uh I
looked at my life and it was like okay I
was really good professionally like
that's how I got to be uh the cell
biologist and the joy of working in that
field of science that uh that was that
was really great but the rest of my life
was a shambles you know it's like I
couldn't get a relationship off the
ground no matter what I tried it was
like oh my God am I I am Dooms here why
because I must have got the parenting
chains and the the from my father and my
mother and I'm not really good at it and
um
so I was working as life as just a
mechanism you do your thing and then
it's dust the dust I had no spiritual
Foundation at all because it was genes
and proteins and chromosomes that's uh
my dear Society knows exactly what I'm
talking about because she comes from a
very serious science background and
that's why when we started collaborating
and talking together it was like oh wow
you know we have this basic
understanding of it uh and and the basic
fact was this okay I'm a machine that's
what we were teaching go to the doctor
that's the repair person fix a machine
and what I learned uh through my
research uh was that genes don't control
life and dreams don't control themselves
and it's like oh my God I spent a whole
career teaching this to medical doctors
that the genes control your life and and
the fear that that's pervasive out there
is that I'm not in charge and I'm
working with what are called stem cells
and this is 50 years ago uh and my
research with stem cells revealed that
genetically identical cells in different
environments have different fate what
does that mean it says well all they
they all have the same genes but the
Fate wasn't based on the genes the Fate
was based on the environment
and all of a sudden I said my research
started to go off and say wait genes
don't don't turn on and off that's a
complete false statement genes are
Blueprints and I go relevant go go into
an architect's office where she's
working on a blueprint and lean over
this architect's shoulder and ask her
hey is your blueprint on or off and she
would look and she's like it's a
blueprint there's no on and off and I go
precisely a gene is a blueprint to make
a protein it doesn't know on and off it
has no control by itself it's not
self-emergent meaning it doesn't control
us it turns out that our perceptions and
the environment we live in and our
perceptions of the environment control
our genetics I go so why is that
relevant I say I can change my
perceptions and all of a sudden it says
I'm not a victim of anything more than
the programming that I got in that that
first seven years uh and it was
interesting because the real the real
part that changed everything for me is
obviously would you had run into before
I did uh was as I said I wasn't
spiritual but as I started to look at
how the environment was controlling the
cells I started to recognize no two
people are biologically identical and so
as I mean I can't exchange cells with
you you can't exchange cells or organs
with me because if I put my cells in
your body your immune system will say
not self and if you put your cells in
somebody else's body their immune system
will save not somebody says what's the
point there's a self
built into your cells that is different
than the self built into your neighbor
cells and I go so why is that wrong and
I said well what is the self and that's
what I started to look at I was like
on the surface of our cells or these
protein antennas just like TV antennas
no two people have the same set of these
protein receptors a name for them is
interesting self receptors receivers of
self and I go when I started looking I
said but these receptors are on the
outside of the cell
and I said so why was irrelevant I said
well if they're signaling getting a
signal of self
the self isn't in the cell the self is
sent to the cell and then all of a
sudden I go wait then the self is not in
here and then I started getting a little
quantum physics started to realize
we are energy units playing through what
we appear to be a physical body
and that our identity is picked up by
these receptors and if I take the
receptors off your cells then your cells
have no identity I could put them into
any human because it's not Salvage these
cells not bruises cells and I go so wait
so I'm still getting there folks there's
a point coming here and I start to
recognize well wait a second
Bruce is a set of antennas well we focus
on the antennas in medicine I go no you
failed to understand
antennas receive a signal
and all of a sudden I started to realize
my identity is something signal in the
environment
that is being picked up by myself
and so Bruce the you know the guy who's
like thinking going all the time going
wait a minute I'm a broadcast Bruce is a
broadcast my my body is a receiver and I
make a joke like I'm a television set
sodvirgin you're watching the Bruce show
right now and the point about it is well
the television can break and we say
television's dead and I go yeah that
happens and I say is the broadcast out
there I said you're watching a show you
say the television is dead and I say
then why I said get another TV plug it
in turn it on and tune it to the station
and you're back on again
and all of a sudden I realized oh my God
and this is it
I can't die
I'm not in here
I'm the broadcast
and then there's all of a sudden it's
like oh my God I can't die uh because
I'm the TV this physical thing and and
what does it mean it says well down the
road a baby is born with what oh the
same antennas that oh I'm back on I got
a new TV set I said does it make a
difference male or female no no that's
the TV set does it make a difference if
it's a black brown red yellow white TV I
said no that's a TV set we are the
broadcasts
and all of a sudden I realized oh my God
all of us come from this energy and this
energy is a field and each of us is a
receiving station of our own little
broadcast out of the field but
collectively we're the radio band we got
all the stations on here we're all in
the same Radio band but each of us comes
in here because you made a this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Joe dispenza check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there it's so important for people to
remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their life the victim is saying I'm
feeling this way because that person
that circumstance or I don't have any
money is causing me to feel this way